in a new variety cover story lil nas ex
is speaking out about his coming out and
how it made him closer to his dad his
mother's addiction issues and his own
marijuana use to cope with family and
friends deaths in the interview the 20
year old rapper spoke quite candidly
about his life saying so much happened
during my rise you know drugs and
murders and my grandmother passing she
was the first person close to me who
died it was devastating and it made me a
hypochondriac I'd wake up heart racing
it was scary to deal with things
lil nas ex admits he started smoking
weed heavily and added but then I
started feeling more connected with the
universe and taking everything as a sign
lil nas ex also opened up about his
personal life
something the rapper doesn't normally do
saying I never really talk about my mom
she's an addict so we don't have the
closest relationship even trying to get
her better things didn't quite work out
but there's still love and after coming
out on Twitter last year he says he has
become closer with his father he said I
mean especially now because I don't have
anything to hide it was a shock for him
it's still the beginning phase I'm not
comfortable bringing a guy around yet
and as for his new role model status lil
Nozick says he does feel pressure but he
also hopes his journey can influence
others he said I hope my actions are
enough to inspire other young LGBTQ
children coming up to not be afraid to
be themselves
[Music]
Lill Nozick's is nominated for six
Grammy Awards at this week in ceremony
and it was just announced that he will
be joined on stage for a one-of-a-kind
performance with Billy Ray Cyrus BTS
Diplo Maison Ramsey and other special
guests for a segment during the awards
called Old Town Road all-stars
how many Grammy Awards do you think he
will take home this weekend what do you
think of lil NAS X's admission that he
feels pressure to be a role model for
the LGBTQ community how did you come out
I'd love to hear your story let me know
in the comments below and don't forget
to subscribe to ET Canada's YouTube page
[Music]